all this stuff is kicking off and it
seems to be very difficult now to
discuss any ideas to talk without people
getting aggravated and insults being
thrown so where are we in terms of our
ability to talk about things as a
society in your opinion Claire I think
you feel as though societies become
tongue-tied in some respects there's a
real sense in which people are very
conscious if they say the wrong thing
they might be attacked for being
offensive for being inflammatory for
saying things which will upset at the
people being accused of inciting
violence so there's a sense of people
walking on eggshells that coexists with
people being entirely unrestrained and
saying the most preposterous thing
whether I can say that and then people
just being utterly abusive in a way you
know and by the way I I think that this
is almost regardless of what kind of
politics you espouse it's not
particularly confined to one group of
people I think the recent parliamentary
spat about inflammatory language cause
some upset because and as you've rightly
pointed out one would never be able to
use a metaphor anymore if you constantly
having say people say you can't use any
battle analogies or any military
analogies well we're in trouble because
we run a festival called the Battle of
ideas for education and and so on so you
know that's what that's where we start
but on the other hand it also felt very
hypocritical because it might well be
that Boris Johnson the Prime Minister
had ratcheted up the language in certain
he was doing very big rhetorical and
kind of huge waves of making himself out
to be the great leader of this big a
brexit battle and people were saying
well you know calm down a bit but these
on the one hand are people who've spent
quite some time accusing other people
have been Nazis fascists you know
leading to the Third Reich and and so on
and so forth and quite violent imagery
has been deployed in terms of trying to
stop and brexit but they want to just
get confined to brexit I'm just saying
that this
sense of double standards in hypocrisy
is something that we have to bear in
mind just wines people a lot but city
wines meal well I mean we're all
according to some people all Nazis in
this room meeting surely isn't that
people's right to you know say what they
think you know if someone thinks you're
a fascist welcome to do that and it
doesn't really have any effect no it
doesn't have any effect if you it only
does if you let it have an effect and
obviously I'm Claire and the actually
the slogan of the back of ideas is free
speech allowed so it's very much about
having that public debate being in favor
of people just saying what they think
but I think the context is key because
at the moment the panic about speech and
words like surrender or humbug or
whatever is that politicians of terrible
word I mean as well as the kind of worry
about escalating language on social
media and the fact it has sometimes
quite serious issues about as class as
abusive lunch on social media is
happening at a time in which we've got a
broad political issue going on which is
a quite deep fear of the public and a
fear of the masses and quite a lot of
prejudice going on and so there's this
sort of when people especially people in
political power and talk about the the
fear of demagogues or Nazis or whoever
is inciting violence through their
speech and the need to kind of everyone
to calm down what it really is is saying
is we've quite scared of having a public
debate because if that public debate
happens then you notice the mob are
going to grab their pitchforks and
they're going to come after us and of
course that's one entirely not true but
it also is it's escalating and creating
a problem that they're afraid of they're
afraid that people are going to get
violent it get rebellious and cause
problems at the same time they're saying
no one talked about anything
no one criticized us no one do anything
anything you say is not just wrong but
illegal and I tell you there's one this
is what people who are interested in
free speech always point out and it's
true that if you want to make a problem
out of something push it underground
sense
give it a kind of glamour that it
shouldn't necessarily enjoy and that's
one problem happens so the antidote is
always sunlight is always more debate as
always more speech and you've got at the
moment a political establishment which
is just so hostile to any kind of
discussion about its actions which I
think it isn't going to end well if it
keeps going down this very censorious
route and this is where the battle of
ideas the festival that you guys run
every year comes in because one of the
great things about that is you genuinely
get people from all over the political
spectrum I mean you know we'll be
interviewing Lord of Darkness who is not
going to be that popular with most of
our probe rakes of view as I imagine but
but you get people from across the
spectrum genuinely and that's one of the
things I really enjoyed well I'm curious
how you managed to do that actually
because we struggle to get like you know
kind of woke leftist guests on because
they are afraid to be even tarnished by
association so how do you get all these
people together well I mean I think
people understand that I think people
are cautious about things being a setup
and so a lot of the time in political
debate in the media for example anyone
who's ever done it knows that you get
put into a room and you get told to kind
of battle it out with each other it can
often be quite fractious the difference
about the festival is because it's
centered around public debate actually
the focus is not on the speaker's
themselves but within their interaction
with a wider audience and so people
understand that this is a genuine
platform where you will be given a fair
shot to try and win over the audience
and I think anyone who's serious about
their political views whether you are a
socialist or a hard right person or ever
view you have what we're essentially
saying is go for it and you might well
completely win over the audience and I
might be devastated because I've lost
the argument but it's a is a fair game
and it has been a fair game for 15 years
and I think people really appreciate
that space to do it and as it happens as
it often is the case that at the
festival and I will enter a room hating
someone's political views and ready to
make contributions floor and really nail
them and come out being convinced that
actually I was being completely
one-sided about something so it's it's
that kind of a
a different space for public debate then
happens within you know media
discussions or other places
[Music]